hey guys I want to do a short video on
Castor oil I'm sure that your
grandparents had this around the house
maybe your parents but it basically
comes from the seeds of the castor oil
plant it's an unsaturated uh fatty acid
which 90% of it has a very special type
of uh fat it's called rinic acid okay
which is
anti-inflammatory which is anti- pain so
you can rub it on joints um it's it's an
antifungal it's good for your immune
system so some people uh put it on their
psoriasis and their skin they rub it
into the skin other people use it on the
eyelashes to help the eyelashes become
thicker stronger and longer especially
if they have an autoimmune condition
where the eyelashes are falling out and
I think the reason why it works because
it's good for the immune system it's an
anti-inflammatory and
anti-microbial antifungal so that's
probably why it works also it's good for
aaxa some women take it to induce labor
if they're pregnant and they need to and
they're overdue um also you can rub it
on the joints and muscles if you have
pain or soreness okay so it's another
natural remedy it's pretty awesome it's
pretty natural the only thing is put a
little bit on your skin first just to
make sure you're not allergic to it okay
before you put it on your eyelashes or
anything like that all right thanks for
watching hi guys Hey listen I created a
pretty amazing evaluation quiz down
below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause so take the quiz now and
we'll send you a report